so in your view should schools reopen to
nursery age children in some primary age
children from June the 1st yes they
should and other countries are opening
up their schools in Europe and Beyond
and so shouldn't we the critical thing
is will parents feel and families feel
confident to send their children into
school safely that's the big issue all
right opening up schools but if parents
lack that confidence then they're not
going to send them in they must be
naturally very apprehensive and worried
and nervous about doing that it seems to
me that the government I've got a real
part to play here in making sure that
parents have the evidence the owners
came out on Friday I don't know why I
came out on Friday because we knew what
the conclusions were of the of the sage
community well before that so the
government should have had two or three
months to really prepare parents for the
opening on the 1st of June and I assume
Iran I don't know
touch this now with what's happening on
the ground I assume all parents have
received a letter outlining what the
evidence is so that they can make a
right and balanced judgment it's
interesting to hear though about our
parents being persuaded that it should
be safe to go back because teachers many
teachers it seems needs a bit of
persuading as well are the unions
digging in their heels some more many
saying that they're not convinced it's
safe to reopen schools and do you feel
that actually maybe they have a point
we're talking about quite young children
here many of them it will be almost
impossible to enact social distancing
with yes social distancing little
five-year-olds give me my curling cats
as I heard somebody say it's going to be
really really difficult but other
schools are doing it not very far in
other countries abroad so we should do
the same it's really important that the
government get the confidence of parents
and teachers and you know they should
have lay down very clear guidelines and
rules under which schools should operate
it's no good saying we're gonna let
to do what they want because some
schools do extremely well and other
schools won't some schools will insure a
truck a triaging system is is in place
that there's temperature testing and
that classrooms are intensively cleaned
and so on and so forth other schools
might not be doing that so it's really
important that the government is very
prescriptive on what it expects schools
to do and remember this local
authorities they've been marginalized in
recent years but they still have a
responsibility for safeguarding even in
academies and free schools they have
that responsibility and the government
should be calling all the local
authorities together now and saying look
you've got to make sure that every
school in your area no matter what its
governance arrangements and its status
are writing a safe environment for
children do you think the government
should also both be prospective in
effectively forcing schools to open if
they're unwilling to well they can do
what they like they can bring in
legislation and for schools but unless
head teachers feel that their schools
are safe and on this parents feel that
their schools are segment and teaches
the same then it's it's a pointless
exercise and that is why the government
really I think should have spent the
last three months preparing the ground
ground well holding meetings with the
teacher associations parent parents
associations and so on to make sure that
all the facts are there transparency is
absolutely critical and parents who
don't necessarily even read all the
evidence from the research bodies need
something to go on to make that balance
judgment and I'm not sure they receive
that whatever happens there's gonna be
some real challenges with people's being
off school as long as they have been
already and do you think we should think
about things like cancelling summer
holidays will some pupils be forced to
resit the whole year I've lost you Oh
hopefully you can hear me now
hopefully be able to hear me now um do
you think summer holidays should be
canceled and will some pupils have to
resit years well I've suggested that
might have to happen with some yo groups
who are taking
examinations can you hear me by the way
I can't hear you yes I suggest that
might be something that is considered
with with your groups who are about to
take examinations year ten groups in
secretary school year twelve group yeah
yeah five in in primary school we wait
and see what's what is absolutely clear
is there a lot of youngsters have lost a
considerable amount of time while this
lockdown has taken place we've had the
report from the Institute Fiscal Studies
and from the SunTrust which showed that
the poorest children particularly have
have regressed and have really lost out
on their education and that's a great
shame because we want every year who to
have the same chances as others if I was
a parent of a year to ten youngster for
example I want that youngster have the
same opportunity opportunities as every
other year that's gone through the
system and it's really the
responsibility of schools and had
teachers when this thing is over and
lockdown ceases and they get the full
school cohort in - they've got to really
ensure recovery programs are put into
place that might mean working in the
holiday periods it might mean we can
work with with examination students I'm
sure head teachers will be thinking
about that and now I mean it's a real
concern isn't it the progress that we've
seen in recent years been wiped out when
it comes to pupils from disadvantaged
backgrounds do you think we could be
talking about almost a lost generation
yes lost generation of youngsters is a
great tragedy because our education
system in England has made huge progress
over the last few years and the Pisa
results which were published last year
show that and it's a great shame that
this could unravel that that that
progress I'm sure it won't if had
teachers when they're in schools do go
grow are absolutely committed to
recovering lost ground that means
convincing teachers to work the extra
hours coming at weekends and holiday
periods to really intensify the work
that that they do with youngsters in
particularly an examination in groups
just finally you said earlier that
schools will be doing different things
when it comes to social distancing and I
think certainly it feels as if schools
have been doing different things
when it comes to teaching pupils online
during the lockdown
Ofsted haven't been appraising schools
on how they've been performing during
the lockdown do you think they should be
yes simply they yeah they should because
Her Majesty's inspectors are not
inspecting at the moment I don't know
when inspection will resume but
inspectors should be surveying the
country to see what is happening
particularly in disadvantaged
communities to see whether Gunnison got
that tops for example our schools
struggling I know some schools that I'm
in touch with are struggling to buy
laptops but children in in necessitous
circumstances so often should be doing
this survey and informing government
what the position is on the ground so a
government can take the necessary action